I just want to start with the next
generation is one of my all-time
favorite shows I am thrilled to be
talking to the two of you about Star
Trek today I really want to thank you
for for making this you know for
everything you've done the work you've
your work I just want to say thanks oh
thank you very kind appreciate it I've
seen the first six episodes of season
three loved them it was it's fantastic
seeing everyone together again
um and I don't know how much you're
allowed to actually say so what are you
what have you been teasing like what
have you been saying to people about
what season three is about well season
two was very much
ins left in suspense
and uh those problems there have got to
be dealt with which is what largely
season three is about and uh it's
dangerous and violent
um and uh
emotional
and it was engaging to be able to act
those seeds
and for for Dr Beverly Crusher it's a
huge leap It's a Wonderful way to begin
because she's being hunted
and has been for quite a while and
running and not understanding exactly
what's going on but for her to actually
say to Picard trust no one
uh and the fact that after all these
years of no contact that she still uh
goes well that's my last hope you know
there's there's something powerful in
whatever that relationship is that she
would
call on him to like I need help so I
think that starts something and of
course you we know that we're not
supposed to talk about it but I don't
know when your article is coming out but
we find out also there's another reason
that she's wanted to be in touch with
him for a long time but because of this
Danger
and she had good instincts about it so
he was really fabulous to come back
having not seen people and uh that she's
been running her own ship and doing it
all you know that was fun one of the
things I thought Terry did a great job
with is that he's nodding to the Past
he's including things that fans are
going to know but it never feels like
fan service perfect you know and I'm
just curious if you could sort of talk
about that that um that if you're a fan
there's a lot there
I agree I think he was really cognizant
of that and he he was saying this is an
Easter egg you know this is something
that we're putting in there
I loved it actually I love um there's a
line that Crusher says at one point but
I can't give it away but it it really
hearkens back to the whole Star Trek
um theme and
it was very moving to me when uh I don't
know how
you know it's the uh the birth sequence
but I I thought that was beautiful
um I loved all that Terry did on it I
thought this the writers did a beautiful
job with all of the characters including
the new characters just Exquisite for
both of you could you sort of talk a
little bit about the fact that this
might you know it's been 20 years I
believe Since Aaron wanted you know done
the roles together and it might not have
ever happened again so what what did it
mean to all to both of you to be able to
you know to do this one more time with
the group of you well but it's not one
more time
it's new it's different
20 25 years have gone by
I'm a different person Gates is all of
us are and so are those characters that
we play and the world has been
transformed they worked out ways in
which
the planets and the Galaxy can be
affected by what's going on elsewhere
and um
so although it's the same title still
Star Trek and although we have the same
names we are living in a different world
from the one of Next Generation or I
don't know if you wanted to add anything
we are close as a group and we all feel
like a family literally with our each
other's lives
but to be able to be acting in scenes
again on a spaceship
to me that was fantastic because it just
felt so easy to be know that we're
different characters but when I lock
into those eyes those are eyes that I
know and love and that adds a just a
depth to it that's that's wonderful this
Beyond character even it's just humanity
and it's our lives we are different
we're acting
roles that have evolved these characters
have evolved
but it's fun I have to stop there I just
really want to thank you both like I
said at the beginning just thank you
thank you and have a fantastic day thank
you you too thank you very kind